joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line former general manager of the
minnesota vikings whose first draft if
i'm not mistaken was the draft in which
russell wilson was taken
when uh he drafted matt khalil and
harrison smith in the first round for
the minnesota vikings joining us here is
rick spielman how are you sir
good thanks for asking and before we get
started if i can
get two quick points out of the way
uh
you know for a first time in my career i
watched the combine from my couch and
watched the broadcast and everything but
the thing that i was looking for
forward to the most
was you running the 40 and apparently
your agent told you to hold out
well i'm gonna do it at my pro day rick
so i didn't know if there was an
announcement on when your pro day was or
when that was going to be but it was the
first only time you were going to have
all the decision makers under one roof i
know that to see the rich eyes and 40. i
know that
i know that rick
i know
um but i'm gonna i'm gonna do it next
month i'm doing it next month here in
los angeles trying to raise as much
money as possible by inviting as many
people in uh because this just didn't
rick unless you you may not know uh the
combine is kind of a closed event and uh
it's not easy to get uh people into that
building you know what i'm saying
well it is on a serious note it's a
great cause and you've just thanks for
great work in that area and uh the other
point that i'd really like to make is i
thought it was a brilliant idea
on mike mcdaniel and the cliche paper on
the head coach's talk
uh with it is what it is i don't have a
crystal ball right all the players we're
going to talk about or the players here
today right but i was disappointed and i
thought maybe i could give you a few
tips maybe cliches if you have a front
office person oh oh look at you rick's
coming with me yeah you were very very
uh not all inclusive at that event all
right a second hold on a minute so so
you you can't you can't tell me that
you've never used those cliches because
you've definitely i'm only talking about
the guys okay so i wanted to share them
with you so if you have uh someone
down the road that if you ever want to
use these um
the first one would be
um
we will stay true to our board and take
best player available
okay that's a good one the other one
would be
this player checked all the boxes
yes i like it what else you got
the next one i know we're 150 million
dollars over the salary cap but we still
want to sign all our players back okay
great
well that's just a falsehood right
that's just that's just false that can't
be true the last one that's the most
important one yes is if you hear anyone
head coach
or front office person say
we have no intent
or intention of training this player
that is the kiss of death that player is
john
rick skillman not a boy oh out of the
gate wow tremendous
oh all of us were just giving you
good answers
it was funny when i i was reading
through the clips and i saw pete carroll
say that i was like i remember
back when i was asked that question on
percy harvard and the exact quote i used
was we have no intent on trading percy
and ended up trading them to seattle a
couple weeks later so then let's get
into it did you have like so what does
that mean no intention why isn't why is
no intention that that smoke signal
what is that
you technically may have no intent to do
that but all sudden you get a deal in
place or you continue to work
on a deal
i was very careful a couple years ago
and i didn't want to use the word intent
when we ended up trading uh stefan diggs
to buffalo
so i i put it in phrases in a different
way but
what made me think about all this was
when you did the
cliche caper uh on coach's talk
uh
just when i listened to all these press
conferences i was trying to read between
the lines of what they were actually
saying and the one that really popped
out was when i heard uh coach carroll
say that about russell wilson and
ironically enough rick uh he was saying
that as mike mcdaniel at the very next
podium to uh pete's right was uh
sticking the triple lindy of coaching
cliches for me
uh rick spielman here uh on the rich
eisenshow former vikings general manager
so when pete carroll said um we have no
intention to trade is that also
potentially uh uh telling george payton
what you're offering is not enough could
that possibly be something like that
yeah there's a lot that goes uh behind
the scenes you know and i've been
involved in a lot of a lot of trades a
lot of big trades and i was very uh
as you know i'm very close with george
payton worked together for over 20 plus
years and we did a lot of deals when uh
he was in not only
miami but in uh in in minnesota with me
and just what's going on behind the
scenes that a lot of times
uh if you're not if you're saying that
there's probably not a resolution on
what the compensation will be but it
doesn't mean that you're not talking
because if that trade does not happen
and he could always come back and fall
and yeah we didn't have any intent to
trade him but no one knows what was
taking place behind the scenes
so what do you think of the compensation
that uh seattle received uh you know
there's always the who won the trade
conversation i'll place that in front of
you rick spielman well
people can talk about it now but you
won't
truly understand what that trade meant
like the one of the biggest trades we
did when i was in minnesota was the
jarrod allen trade um you know and that
ended up working well for uh for us
because jared allen came in and had a
great career hopefully he'll get into
the hall of fame someday
uh he was one of the all-time
best defensive ends in minnesota biking
history in my opinion
um you know you look at when we were
able to trade stefan diggs and buffalo
got a great player that was a very hard
decision that we had to make but we were
fortunate enough to
recover in a draft and get a justin
jefferson so it worked out well for both
sides so i think is what will happen is
you'll have to wait and see
how much russell wilson elevates the
denver broncos you know because they
play in a very tough division with a lot
of great quarterbacks in that big
division will he elevate them get them
into the playoffs and get them to
eventually you do a trade like that
because you're doing it to win a super
bowl but also seattle
they have to have a plan in place so
what are they going to do at quarterback
right now do they fall in love
potentially one of those guys
uh at the combine that are coming out in
the draft this year
there are so many speculation out there
especially from a media perspective well
this isn't a strong class this isn't the
death this isn't that
but
on the inside i know a lot of teams have
spent a lot of time with those
quarterbacks on on board work on
personality on character traits on
psychological testing and you watch as
this goes along uh that one of these
quarterbacks or a couple of these
quarterbacks are going to come up and
start you know rising up people's draft
boards especially they fall in love with
them after they go through all these pro
days and and all the other
uh due diligence they'll do on these
guys and finally i would say the other
point is you know what's going to happen
with the quarterbacks out there now and
our teams
think that hey none of these
quarterbacks are going to fill what we
need and we're going to have to go out
and get an aggressive to get a jimmy
garoppolo or depending on what happens
with the deshaun watson situation and
let's say you know all sudden some of
this legal issues start coming to light
so you actually know what you're going
to be dealing with and but teams have to
have a quarterback so
when you make a trade like a russell
wilson who's such a great player
denver got a great quarterback that
they're expecting them not to get to the
playoffs but eventually get them to the
super bowl but i'm sure seattle had the
plan in place as well on what their next
step is at that position rick spielman
former vikings general manager from 2012
to
last year joining us here on the rich
eisen show so
if do you call bobby wagner now five
minutes ago like how does that work
how does that work rick
you're hearing he's not a scheme fit
this team's already handled an inside
linebacker even if you had a great
inside linebacker wouldn't you call him
like literally right now five minutes
ago well literally i thought you wanted
me to call and see if he'd come on the
show
no i've got bookers for that uh rick i'm
talking about you as a general manager
yeah no i don't have a job right now so
if you need a booker let me know
[Laughter]
if you were in a front office rick like
when you when a player like he like if
his caliber comes available like what do
you think's happening right now new
league year conversations open up monday
some of his caliber comes up what
happens all of a sudden yeah that has an
effect on because technically he's going
to be in the free agent market right and
since they've released them people are
going to start talking now
but that's that's adding depth you know
and i don't know the depth of the
linebackers coming out this year uh in
the free agent market but what teams
will do is can we go out and get a
potential
bobby wagner type linebacker or do we
feel comfortable enough that we don't
have to fill that need
and maybe allocate our resources at
other positions that we need
uh and then we'll fill that with the
cheaper labor if we can draft someone
potentially in the second third round
and or you know a player like micah
parsons which dallas did a great job
taking last year that had such a major
impact so in those front offices and in
those meetings
you are talking about well
we don't feel that the linebacker class
is very strong in the draft so let's go
out and get a bobby wagner or it may be
the opposite listen bobby wagner's a
great player but i think we can allocate
our resources elsewhere at other
positions
and then try to fill the need in the
draft rick spillman here on the rich
eisen show what do you think the market
is for jordan love right now rick
well that was interesting because i was
thinking back you know uh when
green bay had aaron rodgers sitting in
the wings when he was behind brett favre
and eventually they traded brett favre
that went to the jets for a year and
then we were fortunate enough to get
brett favre uh in minnesota uh with us
but
jordan love as you look at it everybody
has their college grades everybody
scouted him and what they felt uh what
type of quarterback he was going to be
it's hard right now
to say where he is at and his
progress is becoming a starting
quarterback or how good a quarterback
he's going to be the only ones that know
that technically are the green bay
packers
because uh what two pre-seasons ago we
didn't have a pre-season uh because of
the covid
uh and last year you know went down to
three games so basically since he's been
in the uh with the green bay packers and
have been drafted by green bay you have
a couple snaps that you've seen through
the pre-season and if that was it and i
don't believe he's really had any
uh significant snaps well he did he did
he did have that start this past year
when reno rogers famously did come down
with covid so i mean he did have that
one start against kansas city so there
is tape on that i guess kansas city
would know but they're not in the market
so what do you think no but that that's
hard to you know you're going off of one
game
right and
you know when you're looking at that
position there has to be
a history behind it because it's hard to
judge especially a quarterback off that
one game
right so what do you think
because clearly he's available and you
know i don't know what your grade was or
if you were if you were not
looking at them because you had cousins
locked up like he was you know garrett
cole with all that uh you know
guaranteed money but uh like what do you
what do you think like it is four years
four years later it sure does look like
a lot as it does the the money's going
out today for these positions right so
what do you what do you think the market
is like guru comes gets a phone call
somebody's like uh
they're they'll buy it
depend on the quarterback needy teams
and
you know where does garoppolo because
you know what garoppolo is you have a
history with him
uh does deshawn watson get traded uh
does trebrisky get you know you've got
some a pretty good feel of what your
briskey is and and what he potentially
could be if he gets in another situation
so i think it's you have some options
out there uh winston still out there as
well so
once the pieces start falling in place
and these quarterback needy teams
make decisions
then you're going to have probably a
better idea if jordan love is tradable
or green bay does want to trade them but
also uh it's supply and demand too
and if teams are going to be more
patient and say well i want to go look
at malik wilson or you want to go get
one of these uh sam howard one of these
quarterbacks in the draft and start
fresh with one of them uh then they may
look at it that way as well so would you
let's say i'll put you in guru kun's
shoes do you call pla places or would
you say you know what i'm gonna hold on
to him and and make somebody call me i
would i would probably sit and be
patient and see if anyone calls me uh
because he's cheap labor he's still
under his rookie contract he's been
developed in that system for the last
two years if something god forbid does
happen to rogers do they feel confident
enough that they have a player in place
that they drafted they can step in and
help win ball games uh if rogers is
missing games due to an injury or
whatever
so you want to make sure that you still
have some depth at that position as well
and probably you'd want to just stay
patient because if you want to go out
and sign a backup quarterback i mean
andy dalton got a 10 million last year i
believe um
so
um and how much are these backup
quarterbacks making right now well if
you feel that you have just a good of a
chance to win in this league with love
than you do with one of the potential
vet back up quarterbacks loves a cheaper
price he's younger he's healthier and
he's been in our system let's stay with
love rick spielman few more minutes left
with the gm formerly or the vikings here
on the rich eisen show
and i'll just um come straight out what
i said yesterday and i think a lot of
people echo it is the
roger staying that
obviously um you know the places that
are most upset about it are minnesota
chicago and detroit
because he's still in the division
and you know detroit has golf and
they're hoping that he can show maybe
this year before they have to make a
long-term decision on him that he is the
right guy and they
bears hope that justin fields is their
guy
and then there's minnesota with kirk
cousins again
um do you think he can win a super bowl
there
rick do you because rogers
no sir
kirk cousins do you think kirk cousins
can win a super bowl there
in minnesota
rick i don't think
you know i think he's a very talented
quarterback he has a lot of great
qualities around him i think he's one of
the most accurate throwers
in the league
you watch some of the tape and some of
the throws he makes under pressure
i think some of the other things he has
to have a very strong supporting cast
around them i don't know how the new
regime feels about him i know he has a
working relationship
with kevin o'connell who i think they
work together in washington and what
that relationship is so it'll be
interesting to see i know you know he's
had a lot of a lot of uh
very good production i know last year
uh we lost a lot of games on the last
rides and there's some of the games that
in overtime that he made some plays to
help us win games he won a big game a
few years ago down in new orleans uh in
overtime for us so
i think usually
these quarterbacks but everything has to
line up and everything has to be not
only
good for the quarterback but the team
gets hot you know you never know in this
league i remember we lost in
to philadelphia eagles in the nfc
championship game and nick foles when
carson once got hurt struggled a little
bit but he got hot at the right time
they beat us pretty significantly uh in
philadelphia went on to win the super
bowl uh with nick fole so you never know
but i do believe that no matter who it
is you have to have
everything kind of a lined up good
defense you know things going on offense
staying healthy and who knows what
happens well obviously look you know
nobody really gets a mulligan in life
but would you give cousins the same
contract again if you could wave a wand
and go back in time would you do that
well you know when we went back and we
looked at we went through that decision
making process uh
you know we got to the nfc championship
game with case
keenum who had a phenomenal year we were
one game away from getting to the super
bowl which was in our stadium that year
and we felt very strongly that there was
very few people
that come
on the market with kirk cousins
uh excuse with
i think her cousins just pulled the
the plug
on his phone
i was like what just happened rick
really want to answer that question
would you give him the contract
we don't like that
you know every once in a while
everyone's away paying attention dj
mikey just answer the phone he's back
he's back on hey guys there we go you
there rick
i had no intent on hanging out
well done
that is fast and that's it for the show
today
as you were saying sorry you were saying
very i was hanging literally on every
word you were saying so
you were saying about kingdom and
everything back in the day so would you
give them the same contract
yeah well we felt very strongly that
that a kirk cousins doesn't come on the
open market like that
and he had a very strong market uh with
other teams pursuing him so we knew
we were going to have if we wanted to
land kirk cousins we were going to have
to do something beyond what was normally
done just because someone like that
doesn't come on the open market and free
agency so we felt as an organization
speaking with our own shift group our
coaches and
and all the decision makers are building
that it was the right move for us at the
time all right well thanks for coming on
the show you checked every box rick
thank you so thank you very much
[Laughter]
thanks for the call yeah it was fun
being on you've got uh we'll chat again
soon thanks for the call
okay thanks for having me on you bet
thank you rick spielman former minnesota
vikings general manager
he brought it
he brought it
you know i and i look forward to having
him on again it'll be great um did you
notice the one word
that he did not say
when i asked him if kirk cousins can win
a super bowl in
in minnesota
what's the one word
that's the word
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here